hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem insert interval
and this is actually another problem
from the blind 75 list a list of 75
common leak good questions that we've
been tracking on this spreadsheet we're
almost done with all of them today we'll
be solving this interval question insert
interval so basically we're given a set
of
non-overlapping intervals and we want to
insert a new interval into this
list of intervals we want the intervals
to remain non-overlapping so basically
we might have to merge some intervals
because we are given a single
interval we're given a list of
non-overlapping intervals in this case 2
5 so when we insert this interval in
here you can see that 2 5 is an interval
right suppose we have 1 3 and then we
have 2 5. so clearly these two intervals
overlap each other right so then we have
to merge them together how are we going
to merge two intervals together well if
they are overlapping we're going to take
the minimum of both of them in this case
it's 1 and we're going to take the
maximum of both of them in this case
it's 5. so that's what the new interval
is going to be right so we merge them
together we'll have a new interval like
this 1 5 and
so this is a new interval and then you
can see we have another interval 6 9 now
6 9 is not overlapping with one five so
in our output now we're gonna have two
intervals right we we're gonna have one
five and six nine and then we're gonna
return these intervals in the output now
the convenient thing is that these
intervals are actually already sorted
for us in ascending order based on their
start times that's good because that
means we are not going to have to sort
them and if you've solved any interval
problems before you know that sorting
always comes in handy for interval
problems and i don't know if they
specify in this problem but just so you
know an interval such as this let's say
we had 1 2 and another interval 2
3 these do count as overlapping because
these two points technically are
connected so this would be one single
interval one
three
i don't know if they mentioned that
somewhere in the description but that is
just an edge case that we'll have to
keep track of suppose we were given a
list of intervals such as these right
these are sorted in ascending order
based on their start value so none of
these are overlapping which is what we
expect what if we were given an interval
such as this one an interval that
actually goes let's say this is zero
right even though i don't know what kind
of interval would end at zero but let's
just assume it is right so that it
doesn't overlap with this one so since
even this interval right
the end value is less than the start
value of the first interval that means
this interval is not going to overlap
with this interval right and if it's not
even going to overlap with the first
interval then there's no way it could
inter it could overlap with any of the
upcoming intervals either right so so
when we basically return our output
we're just going to return this original
list but we're going to add this
interval at the beginning right so that
they're still sort in sorted order and
they're non-overlapping now what if the
opposite was true suppose we were given
an interval such as this one 7
to 8 or something like that right where
the start value of this is actually
greater than the end value of the last
interval right in this case this
interval won't overlap with any of these
and then we can just return the original
list and adding this to the end of the
list right now those are a couple of the
simple cases but it's possible that the
new interval could actually end up
overlapping with one of these
other intervals right and then we'd have
to combine both of these it could be
possible that the interval actually
could overlap with multiple intervals in
the input in which case we have to
combine multiple intervals right or it
could be that the new interval would
actually go somewhere in between a
couple of these and not overlap at all
so how are we going to determine where
exactly this new interval ends up going
well we'll have to go we'll have to
iterate through these sorted intervals
and then basically find the insertion
point of the new interval that we're
looking for so we're going to go suppose
we have an interval like this one right
somewhere small in between here we're
going to go interval by interval we're
going to say okay this is the first
interval does this overlap with our new
interval it does not so we would take
this add it to the output we would look
at the next and we would see that this
interval goes after that and then we go
to the next interval and then we'd see
that okay this n this other this next
interval actually goes after the
interval that we're trying to insert
right suppose we had a really small
interval like this that goes in between
then what would we do well we wouldn't
want to add this one to the result first
we would want to take this this new
interval add it to the result and then
add this to the result and then at that
point we can just take the remaining
intervals and then add them to the
result and then we can return so those
are a couple more of these simple cases
right where we would not have to merge
suppose we had an interval such as
this one though right let's say 0 to
3 or something like that okay we we
iterate through the first interval we
see okay this interval is overlapping
with this one how do we know if they're
overlapping or not well we would check
okay does the end value of the new
interval is it less than the start value
of this interval it's not okay is the
start value of the new interval greater
than the end value of the current
interval it's not so if that if neither
of those are the case that means this
interval does not go after this interval
and it does not go before this interval
so that must mean that they are
overlapping in which case we're going to
merge them how are we going to merge
them we're going to take the minimum of
the left and the maximum of the right
and then merge them together so when we
merge them we're going to get a new
interval such as this one zero two
three and once we have this merged
interval we're not going to actually add
it to the output just yet because we
know that this this interval could
actually overlap with some other
intervals that we now have that come
following right and that's exactly the
case it's overlapping with this other
interval three four so we we've gotten
rid of this first
interval now we're going to be iterating
to the second interval we're gonna see
three four okay is this overlapping with
our zero three interval yes it is so
we're going to merge these as well we're
gonna take the minimum of the left it's
gonna be zero and the maximum of the
right it's gonna be four so we merge
these together so now we're gonna have a
new interval uh from zero to 4 and we're
still
not going to add this to the output yet
because it could technically still be
overlapping with some following
intervals in this case we're going to
get to the third interval and in this
case they're not overlapping how do we
know that because the end value of this
one 4 is less than the start value of
the interval that we're at so what are
we going to do we're going to take this
the first interval add it to the result
now and then we're going to take this
interval add it to the result after it
and then we're going to go to the next
interval see that we don't have any more
intervals remaining and then we're done
so this is going to be our result in
this case 0 4 and 5 6 our new intervals
after we've merged them and they're in
ascending order so that's kind of the
general algorithm as you can see since
it's already sorted we'll just have to
iterate through the entire list of
intervals once so the overall time
complexity is going to be big o of n
that's also going to be the memory
complexity
if you count the memory that we're going
to use to create the result array with
that being said we can hop into the code
now into the code and so we are going to
have a result a result of intervals and
as i mentioned we're going to be
iterating through every single interval
in the input we're given a list of
intervals they're already in sorted in
ascending order so now we want to know
the couple edge cases remember so
basically if this new interval uh
suppose it goes before the current
interval that we're at so suppose the
end value of this new interval is
actually less than the start value of
the interval that we're at so how do we
get the start value well interval at
index i at the zero value this is the
start value and so basically if the new
interval has an end value that's smaller
than the start value of the current
interval we're at what are we going to
do well that means we can go ahead and
take this new interval and insert it
into the result so we'll say result dot
append new interval and once we're done
with that then we basically know that
all the intervals that come after it are
also going to be non-overlapping right
so we don't really have to do anything
we can just take those additional
intervals append it append them to the
result and then return so in python an
easy way to do this is result uh plus
intervals the sub list starting at index
i going until the end of intervals right
so we can just take that entire sub list
and append it to result this is you can
do that with the addition operator and
then we'll just return that right we
don't even have to continue this uh
while loop now the opposite case we
discussed remember was else if
this new interval actually goes after
the current interval that we're at well
in that case that means the new interval
could actually still be overlapping with
some intervals to the right so we're not
going to add the new interval to the
result
let me write the condition so basically
if the new interval the start value of
this new interval was greater than the
end value of the interval that we're at
then we're to the result we're going to
go ahead and append that interval that
we're currently at because it's not
overlapping with this new interval but
we're not going to append the new
interval just yet because it could
technically overlap with some additional
following intervals that are coming up
and the last condition so these two
conditions are if the new interval was
not overlapping but the last condition
else if neither of these evaluates to
true that means the new interval is
overlapping with the current interval
that we're iterating through so what are
we going to do well we want to update
the new interval in that case right we
want to merge it with the interval that
we're at and remember we how are we
going to do that well we're going to
take the minimum of the left value of
both intervals so this is how we can do
that the
minimum of the the new interval and the
minimum of the current interval we're at
and the maximum of the right value of
both of these so let me copy and paste
and the right value is going to be at
index one so we just have to change
those indexes so this is what the new
interval is going to be set to now once
we've updated that new interval right we
basically merged it with a different
interval are we going to add this new
interval to our result well not quite
because remember this new interval could
still be overlapping with some
additional intervals that are coming up
so we're not going to add it just yet
and then at the end so once this entire
loop is done executing we're going to go
ahead and return the result right but
remember one thing so there's two ways
that we could have exited right
one is that if we ever got to the point
where the new interval was uh basically
if this if condition ever executed if
the new interval was not overlapping
with a interval then we go ahead and add
that new interval to the result and then
we return right but if that never
executes then we're never going to end
up adding the new interval to the result
right so what we want to do before we
return the result is go ahead and take
to result.append that new interval
before we return right because that
means basically we definitely want to
append this new interval to the result
right that's kind of what the function
was telling us to do insert the new
interval so we want to make sure that we
do end up executing that so
once that's done we have written the
entire code and as you can see it is a
pretty efficient solution so i hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it supports the channel a
lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching